well I think eventually when you have
ideological forces that are strong that
are frustrated that they will out in the
long run it is it is a serious problem
the entrenchment of these two parties
but you know you have what sixteen
percent support for Congress today and
twenty-four percent for the Republican
president I mean there's a lot of
dissatisfaction and eventually something
will give I'm convinced that if you got
rid of contribution limits that you
would have these two new parties and and
it's interesting because my friend gene
McCarthy who passed away a couple of
years ago used to say had that had the
1974 amendments to the federal election
campaign act been in place in 1968 when
he challenged London Johnson of his own
party he would not have run I mean gene
McCarthy got hundred-thousand-dollar
six-figure contributions from steward
mod and other wealthy liberals that
allowed him to challenge Johnson and in
fact knock out a sitting president from
his own party gene didn't get the
nomination but he wouldn't have run he
said had those thousand dollar limits
which came out of the 74 amendments been
in place that so I think these these
limits on contributions as long as you
have full disclosure which I'm perfectly
willing to give up even though
philosophically I don't think you should
have to disclose but okay I think
there'd be market pressure to disclose I
think people would say well where'd you
get your money and if you could say I
got my money from these people because
they believe what I believe and that's
how we're going to run this campaign
that would be fine and then you'd be
able to challenge the incumbents but the
way it is now it's almost impossible